let's go to louie from new brunswick
which new brunswick are you calling from
louie
hey david um this is new brunswick new
jersey actually love it what's going on
there
all right well i want to ask you a
question there's um
there's some diseases that affect
certain people groups
uh historically so for example sickle
cell
might affect african americans more sure
tay sachs might affect
oh
what would you say
jews um
jewish people i guess you could say are
people from middle eastern descent is
that correct am i correct and say that
tay sachs is absolutely one that is uh
more prevalent in the
ashkenazi jewish community i don't know
about sephardic but yes point taken
so what i want to say is that
is trumpism
like a spiritual disease that affects
white
americans more than others
i don't think there's any genetic basis
for it i think it's a cultural basis um
i i love your framing of the question
because we're thinking of trumpism as a
disease and that that's really
interesting but
um i think it's it's more of a uh
cult-like cultural
thing and a cultural disease it's a
cultural disease exactly right so i
think that it happens to afflict more
white people
for cultural reasons not for genetic
reasons
of course i saw something really
interesting i went for christmas i went
to um for christmas break
i went down to the maryland area and we
went to a mall with the family
and i noticed something really strange
um
people who were wearing masks in the
mall and there wasn't a mandate i guess
it was voluntary okay but we're almost
entirely non-white i'm talking about
like african-americans latino americans
masking up whereas the uh the white
americans like almost no mask my entire
family noticed it we're
from new jersey as i mentioned before
and it was just really really shocking
so what did it mean what did you take
from it what did what what what was your
take away
well
you know we we had a lively discussion
about what it all meant and
um i i it really boiled down to what we
thought was entitlement like we have the
freedom not to wear a mask
uh you know i didn't have any like
discussions with anybody uh head-on or
anything this is just you know
speculation but it was it was really
prevalent like everyone noticed it from
my family so i thought that was pretty
interesting
louis you raised some fascinating
questions i appreciate you calling in
today
all right take care all right there's
louis from new brunswick wow that is
that is quite a call
all right everybody that's gonna do it
for calls today i'm so glad i got to
speak to many of you i know i didn't get
to speak to everybody but we will have
another opportunity we'll take a quick
break and be right back